hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday
during my episode 5 review I asked you
to submit all your questions about you
know WTF Craster's Sansa are in the
Hound everything else so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one
bonus question I also have a huge huge
thank you to say to all of you guys for
being so amazing because as I'm posting
this video I just hit 200,000
subscribers so I never expected to this
to happen I'll try to do a special
announcements video later this week
that'll kind of explain some of the new
stuff that I'm working on right now but
thank you so much also high fives to
Shelley Somers and Matt Dave you are
this week's giveaway winners you both
win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
contacting you on your channels for
details so the next round of the
giveaway starts after episode 6 airs
whenever I post that video so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get that now let's answer
some questions you guys had a lot of
good ones this week so it was really
hard to pick but careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet but here we go question 1 amore asks
why did Locke want bran and what was he
gonna do with them so if you remember
all the way back to at the dreadfort
with Theon and Ramsay snow they
basically told Roose Bolton that the
star children were still alive right now
Roose is supposed to be ruling in the
north but as long as the stark children
are still alive bran and Rickon that is
people could rally support behind them
so Roose sent Locke to capture them so
they could prevent any challenges to
their rule he was never going to kill
them you know Roose Bolton isn't as
vicious as Ramsay but they would have
still been prisoners question number two
Jessica asks is arias direwolf Nymeria
still alive and is she going to be back
in the story so Nymeria is still alive
but george RR martin has been really
vague on whether or not she's going to
come back into the story or arya is
gonna see her again so it's currently
unconformity be getting a lot of
first-person perspective wolf shots
whatever brand wargs into summer so
until we get confirmation just assume
that Nymeria is running free somewhere
between Winterfell and the Riverlands
just out in the wild question number 3
Emily Whittle asks how long do you think
Ari and the Hound will stay together
yeah they really did tease us with Arya
saying his name during the prayer and
him actually hearing it and just taking
notice and then her trying to stab him
with knee
I think it says a lot that the blade did
not penetrate his armor
I think it's Dave and Dan just letting
us know that they're gonna be together
for a while longer I'm all in favor for
them staying together all season but
clearly things cannot go on the way they
are now forever
she definitely hates him and there's no
way their story is gonna get a happy
ending all nice and clean I feel like on
Game of Thrones we've learned to just
wait for the rug to get pulled out from
under characters so I'm really waiting
for something to happen between the two
of them for all the book readers out
there - personally I would not flip out
if they completely change the book plot
and did something totally crazy remember
what happened with the White Walkers you
know they did an extra scene that wasn't
in the books but technically was part of
the timeline so they could do a lot of
those things with Aria in the Hound
question number four hombres asks what
do you think will happen to King's
Landing because of all their debts so
after I made my review video I actually
saw Mark Gatiss inside the teaser for
episode six
so he is actually gonna give you that
answer I think the bank is going to
threaten to fund Stannis unless the
throne can repay their debt remember a
Lannister always pays his debts and
right now it looks like the Tyrells are
their only option there are a couple big
things the Tywin could choose to do he
could try to discredit the Tyrells and
seize their assets and you know use
those to pay off the bank or he could
just ask them for help and they could
genuinely just trade money for like a
seat on the small council or something
else of value question number five
Genesis this asks how come Cersei was so
civil towards Margaery so there's
actually a couple things going on here
first she's still completely mentally
and emotionally fried from Joffrey's
death and she's still reconciling the
reality of his craziness remember how
she talked about how he shocked her so
she doesn't have the energy to hate
right now she's just thinking about
Tommen's future which leads to the
second big reason she really wants
Tommen to stay pure like he is right now
and she knows that he needs more
positive influences in his life even
though technically according to
Littlefinger everyone in King's Landing
is a liar so she's really just trying to
appeal to Margaery sense of goodness you
know I think she understands what
Margaery is capable of but inside I
think that Margaery is a good person
think about how shocked she was when
Lady Olenna told
how she killed Joffrey obviously with
the help of Littlefinger and sir Dontos
question number six
yo kandar asks when will we see kendry
and yara Greyjoy again so actually yeah
a lot of you guys have been asking me
about Gendry and he's definitely still
alive the show wouldn't just forget
about him after he rode away from
Dragonstone it's possible that they
could combine the yara Ironborn story
with gendry's escape they're both on the
right side of Westeros Gendry was
originally supposed to wrote to King's
Landing but I do not think that he's
gonna make it there and in the teaser
for episode six we do see Ramsay snow
and yara but no Gendry so we'll have to
wait and see another possibility is is
that Gendry could run into Arya again
I'm not expecting that but they're both
on the right side of Westeros I mean
Arya is headed east question number
seven Stephenie Herrmann asks do you
think that next season we'll get into
winds of winter stuff because the show
is moving so fast no actually I don't
because there's a lot of Dance with
Dragons stuff that I haven't seen yet
they really have slowed the pace of the
story down and think about how short
some of Daenerys scenes have been she
was barely in this episode what I do
think will end up happening is that will
get more sidetracked side stories like
the White Walkers in the last episode
and Craster's in this episode some of
the directors have already said that
they expect more big deviations to come
up as the show gets further along so
don't plan on seeing any winds of winter
stuff till season six at the earliest
remember we are shooting for eight
seasons so they want to stretch this out
as much as possible so I think we'll
just see a lot more scenes that weren't
originally in the books question number
eight Lexi Bell asks what was the whole
reason for the Craster's house plot with
bran lock and Jon Snow so also a bunch
of stuff going on right here first you
have Locke a character that was not in
the books then you have brand who really
isn't even in the story at this point
the whole brand going to find the
weirwood tree is part of Dance with
Dragons that's way ahead in the story so
they did like a Theon Greyjoy thing
where they add extra story to fill the
gaps in the timeline plus they had
burned Gorman's character which actually
was in the original books even though
they changed it a little bit in the
Nights Watch revolt they had to tie all
those plots up and put a nice little bow
on it so that's really what Craster's
was for now bran is back on track the
revolt has been put down and Jon Snow
can worry about the impending
Modelling attack and the lock character
who was significant but not part of the
original story is taken care of remember
sometimes characters aren't in entire
books like fian was not in book three
but they had him in season three so they
just had a lot of filler to fill in
those gaps question number nine Ryan
Birds asks will we ever see the
Brotherhood without banners again so the
Brotherhood is still in the Riverlands
right around the crossroads brian is
headed in that direction with Podrick
looking for Sansa so if anyone runs into
them it will be her so if we see them
again it will be part of the Brienne
plot I know everyone keeps asking me
about Lady Stoneheart there has been no
indication that she's gonna be on the
show so I do not want to talk about her
too soon also people who have read the
books when you're talking about Lady
Stoneheart be careful for spoilers in
the comments below just for people who
are only watching the show question
number 10 Peter Ruben asks how old
Bravo's come into the show so I think
Mark Gatiss will be our first real
introduction
although the bank has branches in all
the kingdoms of the world its central
office is just located in Braavos as for
that scene of the Titan from the
trailers we saw it again in the teaser
for episode 6 so I'm guessing that
Stannis and sir Davos will go there to
get more money those scenes were
actually sown in conjunction with Davos
on the ship in Davos pleading with
someone so I really am thinking that
they're going to Braavos right now at
least in the next episode and one last
bonus question Curtis Curtis asks do you
think that Daenerys will end up writing
one of her dragons eventually I would be
so bummed if she did not they've been
teasing it quite a bit so I'm pretty
sure that they're gonna do it eventually
because it seemed like that would end up
being such a huge payoff I think they'll
probably save it for the finale if they
do end up doing it so don't expect to
see something of that magnitude until
episode 10 remember how that final shot
at season 3 was of all those people
lifting her into the air don't you think
a perfect way to visually call back to
that would be for drogon to literally
lift her up into the air
and then BAM slam to black for another
year until season five comes that's
really just my opinion but I think it
would be the perfect way to end season
four so thank you so much for submitting
questions guys these are always a ton of
fun to do and thank you so much for
helping me get to 200 dozen subscribers
so you're all amazing and awesome like I
said I'll try to post an updates video
just for all the new stuff that I'm
working on sometime this week but
my next bonus video for Game of Thrones
will be all about Braavos all about the
culture and the organizations like the
faceless ones and the iron bank be sure
to subscribe to get that if you're
finding me for the first time right now
click here to get my review of the
episode and click here to learn all
about the first war with the White
Walkers and the building of the wall so
thank you so much I'll see you guys
tomorrow so I need to give away 200,000
hi-5 so I'm gonna leave this here for
just a second ok see you guys bye